But it's not an ethereal thing like a
thought, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like,
so here's one of fiddy of
phobia or rack neophobia,
fear of snakes or spiders.
Those that, have you ever
seen anybody who has that? Oh,
you were on fear factor with
me. Oh my God. That was awesome.
That was the word I should say. You
were, you made it out bro. Boge laces.
No. Do you remember I was on this in
one episode one I was the pilot episode,
the pilot episode. That's where
I met you for the first six T.
Can you believe 16 what? 2001
yeah. What does that, what are we,
it's eight 18 years ago
we met because that was,
that was right after nine 11
yes. Yeah, right after it.
And they flew us down and
the first time I met you,
it was that saddle ranch and you're
like, welcome this dude. Oh Man.
Okay. This, this is later.
This is later is way later when we did
the new season of it in like 2011 yeah.
You tried to get me to eat that spider.
Yeah.
That's when I was acting like a spad
bro. Dude, dude, that's not a normal,
and you just chomped it like a chance.
So this whole scene,
I'm acting like a little bit,
how a little,
little fearful you had eat sheeps,
eyebrows, eyeballs to eat. Dude.
Now those were disgusting. Have
you ever, did you eat the sheep?
He did because I felt bad for you guys.
That was before I had hardened.
I'd been hard into the world as you
guys were episode one. Season One.
It didn't seem right for me that you
guys would have to eat these things and I
didn't need it. So I said, all right,
if you guys eat it, I'll eat it too.
But they didn't show it like they wouldn't
show it on television that I ate it
because they didn't like, they didn't
want it to look too easy. Yeah.
So weird shit. But yet, oh my God.
I remember biting down into it and it kind
of like burst. Yeah. Then that retina,
the, he had to just chump change. Yeah.
You had to chew on that rent and
we had to eat three of them. Yeah,
they weren't good. No, they were horrible.
But you know, it was surprisingly mild.
I ate a roach. Well, I'm not not bragging,
it's a place like much just a Roche
even though it doesn't taste like much.
Like why don't you eat a roach?
Is that part of the show?
It was a celebrity fear factor.
And um,
there was a young lady who was
scared to eat a roach and uh,
she was going to get eliminated from
the show. And so I said, listen,
I'll make you a deal. I'll, if you do
it, I'll do it. And she's like, you will.
I go, yeah, I will. And she wouldn't do
it. So she made a deal like three worms.
She decided I'll eat three warm, like
we can go shoot up to three more times.
And so then I ate a row.
I remember when I was on that show,
the question they would ask you in the
survey is, what's your fear of dying?
And I wrote down dying on the water
because that would be my biggest fear is
dying underwater.
And so the,
our last stunt was when they dumped us
on the water and my friends still send me
screenshots of that because that's when
I had long hair and I'll put a bunch of
gel in it and they dumped me under the
tank and literally it looked like a squid
shooting out. Oh my God. If you
could Google it, Google Michael,
Yo uh,
fear of fat and it's,
my friends will just screenshot that
and they still play that to this day.
They still play that episode of your
family. All of them. They play him on um,
different like true TV or something like
that. One of those, I remember those.
I remember when we were
talking I'll go cause you are,
what show were you on at that time
was radio. You were on news radio.
That was a couple of years
earlier. Hey, you are, look
at that. What happened? Yeah.
And okay, so that's the
cheap, I bought Michael Yo
cheap sai bowls.
So at the Ed at the ed I go
to Joe and I go, hey man,
I can't do the last dot.
Look at that. I can't. Okay.
So this is you talking to me cause
Joe goes, Joe goes, hey, I, I go Joe,
I'm not going to be able to make
it through this whole stunt.
I can't hold my breath for
that long. And you go, oh,
just make it look great for the camera.
So what I,
I was going to try to talk you into it,
but I wasn't good enough at it.
Then I did.
I had to figure out how to talk people
into it because I knew there's some
people that were just psyching themselves
out yet in the smoker one our episode,
that guy that we thought that was
going to lose no oxygen. Yeah,
it's fucking system.
He's used to having no oxygen and that's
when they cast it fear factor Alpha
personality. And then it just became a
hot fest. Like if you're a sexy of it.
It was also, um, you know,
they kept ramping up
the difficulty of stuff.
Like the last season scared the shit
out of me when they were launching a car
through a moving train and an explosion
happens when the car looks like what you
can kill somebody. Like, and
when I came up to your, uh,
I think it was the last season,
y'all are doing something with a donkey.
Dong Daci come that's
got canceled. Yeah. Yes,
because I remember showing up
and Joe says, come here Yo,
you're about to try talking.
Like what was so crazy,
everybody was going to quit when I showed
up that day and they brought the paper
into my trailer and they told
me what it was going to be.
I don't think I knew about that one
before. Some of them I had known about,
knew about before,
but I don't think I knew about that one.
I think when they brought that in,
I had no idea and I was like,
you can't do this. I'm like, no
one's going to do it. First of all,
they're all gonna quit.
But what was hilarious is I'm sitting
there next to you watching them drink this
stuff.
We're just laughing.
How about an intern had a drink
it and intern had drinking.
I think they only got like $100.
What for what? Well there was like,
part of the thing is that they
would have to test it when,
when they would like say
here's some fear factor info.
So like say if you had to eat
like a kidneys, right? How many,
how many kidneys can someone eat in
a minute? You know, like how much,
how much meat can you
actually look consistent,
gusting dried meat can you consume?
And so what we had was certain interns,
they would volunteer for it and they
would get like an extra hundred and
something dollars and I would
always give him money too.
I was getting a couple hundred
bucks on top of it, but they would,
they would eat whatever the fuck it was
and then they would determine all right,
well Mike usually can put it
down like, like, like no one.
And if he could only get through three
and then some other producers would come
in and go, fuck this. We're being pussies.
Making me for like for you guys are crazy.
And this was like the debate,
the bay debate on the set would be
like how much blood did they drink?
One Gallon, one gallon of blood,
like they never drank but,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like how many horse Dicks,
they never had a horse deck, but they
did eat like what? What's six and elk?
Dick's and deer. Dicks. But the
donkey come was the worst. Oh yeah.
And I even remember at the
shit you were like, yeah,
I think the show's over after
this. I like, they didn't air it.
I think they didn't, they couldn't even
other countries though of did it. Really?
Yeah.
So he could get it like in,
I think it's like Dutch
and so it's like you hear,
you hear us talk in English but then
they have Dutch subtitles. Yeah, that,
that was, that was such
so stupid. It's so, Doug,
are you surprised how
stupid people are to go? No,
because I think people are
like, look, it's an experience.
I'm here for the experience. I'm
going to have some fun. This is crazy.
But when you get to donkey come yet
you're kind of being rude. Yes folks.
You know you got donkey,
this donkey,
then the donkey come is like an advantage
of their need for fame in a weird way.
No you are. But Hey, they want
to give it, that's the game.
And I remember you showing it to me
first and it was in this large glass
container and they, and it wasn't a
little, they had to drink. No, no, no.
It was like to drink a lot.
Yeah.
It was like the aforementioned
rhino horn beer mode.
Fuck large chunk.
Yeah.
You know what's even more offensive
on donkeys are they're not fertile.
Look at it. There it is. Oh that's
him. Yes. So that come is useless.
It's not just come.
But imagine it's like it's,
it's come that can never even
be babies. Okay. To Mail Shit.
But I remember when y'all used
to do stuff, this is disgusting.
I remember I used to do stunts.
It was actually a delicate,
like people in other
countries that actually ate
it sometimes. Both. Sometimes.
Yeah. Like balloon. So that's not, that's
just being done. It's just being me. Okay.
That's no other country is doing that
just for fun. Keep up on that whole, uh,
this in other countries,
this is considered a delicacy.
He gave up on that in a long
time ago. Yeah. You had to
push the envelope on that.
Now one of the things that
made things gross smell wise,
it was actually really expensive
cheese. They would go to this, uh,
expensive was if a full monitoring,
what do they call them?
What are they call one of those cheese
places like Italian for cheese for my
Tomas formality is for my shirt.
Isn't it French too?
Something like that is my,
that's my translation.
They both come from that. I'm dumb.
I'm dumb. So there you go. But anyway,
this cheese that we
would use was disgusting.
It smelled so bad,
but apparently it tastes really good
if you're into that kind of cheese.
Like Bordain was really into stinky
cheese. Like would talk to me about it.
Like with passion like that,
just the,
the fucking stinkier the
better like disgusting smelling
cheese and the taste is
fantastic. I'd be like, wow.
I would think that the smell which we're
turning you off taste buds. Absolutely.
I don't know.
It's like one of those things where I
guess you catch like the right vibe,
like you going in with the right attitude.
There is no attitude. If it stinks,
fuck that dude is anything
that smells cheese.
And they would squeegee it off into a
blender and then they blend it up with the
other stuff,
like worms and shit.
It would make the worms taste
horrific or smell horrific. Oh,
so you were just messing
with the smell sense.
So it can make it seem like it was worse
than the way can get worse because it
smelled worse. So it was
making more like smell it, but
people would just start retching more.
It was,
it's a ridiculous fucking thing.
It's a ridiculous thing to
the show is really silly. No,
but I, I love that these people wanted to
be famous or you know, and that too, bro.
But I wasn't, but no, no, no, no.
But I was different to me too. That is
different too, because how it happened,
I was in Austin, Texas and there
was an ad in a paper that goes, hey,
have you ever done anything
adventurous? And I was like, no,
let me go in for this Cathy.
I was a radio DJ out there and um,
at this radio station. So
I go in and then Mikey, uh,
they called them the chimp.
He was the casting person.
And literally two weeks later,
three weeks later,
I'm in Hollywood shooting this
thing and then I meet you.
And then I remember going up to you,
cause I was in all,
it was the first time in a Hollywood,
I'll go and I knew you from news, right?
And I was like, how do you do it? And
you're gonna just fucking be yourself.
You can be successful.
And that's what you're doing right now.
Just fucking being yourself.
That's what you're doing to where,
where we're trying, we're
trying this. And I did listen,
let ridiculous piece of
advice. Just be yourself. No.
Do whatever you do.
Don't improve
right now forever. Good luck.
Just be yourself. That's all
you need, Bro. That's it.
Just tell you wrong. Just believe in
your dreams and make a vision board.
Joe was just trying to get me on his
face. Oh, just be you. All right?
But it that is the right
advice if, especially if you
want to be an entertainer,
if you can figure out how to be
yourself as long as yourself is actually
something interesting and if
it's not working yourself. Yeah.
And then you even said that
about acting and he's like,
I remember specifically
saying, aw, act is not hard.
It's just you yourself and you
play that emotion. And I was like,
oh that sounds easy.
You like if they can comparison to stand
up in some ways but does not like a
disrespect,
like the kind of shit that like Daniel
late Daniel Day Lewis and Leonardo
Dicaprio. Well yeah, when they, when they
get into a fucking roll and you're like,
God damn that guy just own that shit.
Like they get into what I'm talking about
like sitcoms, acting. Yeah. Sitcom Act.
And they were hiring you to be easy
at that time. 100% yeah. So it was a,
a slightly dumbed down version of me
who is into slightly more conspiracy
theories than me when I was on news
radio. That's how it was. Yeah.
It was basically me,
like they wrote a lot of that conspiracy
shit in after I'd talked to them about
like JFK and fucking no Ufos and stuff.